hey there what's going on today we're
looking at investigating human priors
for playing video games by ratchet dooby
phuket agrawal Deepak Patek Tom
Griffiths and Alexey I a for us so there
is a paper to go with this but I
actually don't want to get into the
paper too much in order to not reveal
too much of what's coming but basically
they're trying to investigate what makes
video games work for humans so what the
humans pay attention to what priors
bring humans into a video game and the
fun thing is they've created these games
where they oblate these individual
priors and we are going to play them so
the original game right here as you can
see is kind of this montezuma's revenge
type of game so you only need the arrow
keys if you go to a bad blob like this
then you die and you can jump on them
and you can use the ladders and the
spikes they'll hurt you if you jump on
them and also if you fall down between
the platforms so what you got to do is
basically get the key then go to the
door over here and bada-boom cool so
let's try out so they they they
basically oblate different things here
mask semantics means that you don't know
what the objects are anymore so you
might go over here and you might be like
what's this green thing can I jump on it
oh so we're probably a bit biased
because we've seen the game before so we
know that these are the that the pink
ones are the bad ones and that's the key
so we should probably get it but you can
imagine that it is a bit harder but you
could still solve it right
reverse semantics is very interesting if
you play it for the first time because
all of a sudden now there's the coins oh
and the fire but I think humans could
probably still figure it out with like
some minimal trial and error right this
ice cream cone you realize okay now it
gets interesting
because right now we've always had sort
of we know that there's an object and
there's no object on the platforms but
now these are masks so basically you
don't know what's like a relevant object
and what isn't so I know that there's
like a bad thing here and a bad thing
down to the left so I
I'm gonna guess these light aha these
light pink things are the bad things
yeah yeah these are the ladders cool bad
thing right here hey we are rocking this
okay kee where's that that's the key and
the door so it gets harder because you
kind of have to remember the colors
right I know that the light pink ones
are the bad squares still still solvable
so um let's jump over these on the left
because these gets really actually it's
going to here so in masked affordances
if what what they're saying is that okay
you can kind of from the way something
looks you can tell what you can do with
it for example the platform's you can
you know jump on them and the background
is sort of empty space so you know that
there's nothing much happening there so
they trying to take that away by simply
re texturing all the objects here such
that you don't know how you can interact
with them and it does get significantly
harder because okay so these these green
ones are these green ones are the
platforms right here so but I can still
see that that must be the ladder right
you can imagine if you were playing this
again for the first time that this is
significantly more difficult but you
still see the key and the green ones
being the platforms we got this now it
gets harder
masked visual similarity so this is
where they say maybe as we did so far
maybe you as a human can kind of make
out that things that are visually
similar to each other can you can do the
same things with like we said all the
green ones are probably the platforms so
they took it away
haha gee ok so that must be ok can't go
here fell down let's try again this is a
platform is this one here yes
these are platforms that was easy too
easy too easy running into that bad Bob
there
okay the ladders are still like this but
then okay
yeah this gets harder as you can t okay
I'm too dumb to remember from before I'm
like the ideal subject because I don't
remember how how did this work I'm going
to solve this just so you know even if
this video gets to 50 minutes I'm going
to make it through this okay ah here we
can okay see my short-term memory is so
bad okay we got the key now just get
over to the door doors over there yeah
okay
let's wipe the short-term memory again
here changed ladder interaction where
they basically say okay one of the
things that you could know from the real
world is how you know these objects work
in the real world so there's not really
any pink blobs with evil faces there
might be spikes
yesBut ladder is something you know that
works so if you want to go up here that
doesn't work so you kind of have to
figure okay so you have to go kind of
left and right to go up the ladders and
so that one I actually tried before and
I figured that out pretty quickly I
think humans are able to figure that out
fairly quickly because you kind of on
the ladder right you can actually go
down and easily you you're on the ladder
and then if that kind of doesn't work
and then you kind of try to wiggle
because there's two of them I don't
think that's that's necessarily super
hard and now it feels a bit like you
know this Super Mario maker thing where
where people just try to make levels as
hard as possible and trick you with
trick blocks and invisible stuff this is
hard so the direction of gravity is
another left key jumps right and here
this key so this is like this is
extremely extremely hard ah because I
have to like think about every move I
make before I do it and okay now this is
so unintuitive for real yeah got it got
it okay really try this out this is
crazy
yeah
okay so the last thing is we combine all
of it I guess except it changed gravity
and changed interaction so now all the
priors all the visual object priors
removed this is this is Kings discipline
right here okay so we figured out where
the blue cool so where's the next this
is the next platform
we're step okay there must be like it
yeah take that okay but we know the next
so we can't really generalize from this
because we know the next bad blob isn't
going to be the same color right okay
white then this I know there's a bad
thing here but we'd have to figure this
out so basically kind of the point of
the paper I think is to say that this is
what you're doing to or know the spikes
this is what you're doing to RL
algorithms if you're in the most case so
they simply have to go and to basically
try every single thing and remember what
worked and what didn't work now of
course the RL algorithms can also
exhibit like can also use the visual
similarity that was the key yeah yeah
let's get the door door don't know there
is it there's like a bad thing here
right no spikes
[Music]
so either we build these priors into the
oral algorithms if we want to get them
to human level or we have some sort of
learning these priors before we let the
people go
you know onto a paper or I don't I don't
know or we just you know take it that
orell algorithms you know have to figure
all of this out by themselves so they
oblate these things right here
you can see the masked object identity
makes kind of the biggest difference in
terms of time number of deaths the
number of states explored reverse
semantics I believe these are humans
that are you know trying it for the
first time and they're just like oh and
ice cream so it can also hurt right your
algorithm wouldn't be super impressed by
it looking like an ice cream but the
human is very much and the crazy thing
here you can see exploration the
original game and then exploration in
the no object prior game especially if
you play this for the first time this is
just mad like no freaking way I would
actually like love to see video games
like this coming out this would be the
worst selling video game of all times
where dynamically it just removes these
kind of priors but it's a I think it's a
really fun way to investigate what
humans learn and what they already bring
into the game so here they have another
game and they do this same thing on an
RL agent and you see here the RL agent
just don't care about any of these
things except visual similarity so
visual similarity helps the RL agent to
generalize across the game so if you see
a bad blob the next bad blow-up will
look similar and that's sort of kind of
an invariance that we know they can
exploit since they're using
convolutional neural networks and so on
but I think it is really drawing
attention to the importance of priors
prior knowledge in reinforcement
learning and human knowledge so in this
game right here where you have these
hidden rewards that the human doesn't
see right but if they kind of touch it
they're kind of coins and the human
performs way worse than the RL agent
because the RL agent will actually try
those things out and the human having
the prior that the black think this
don't see the yellow boxes that the
black thing is just empty space
they won't even explore that so maybe
you know that is something to think
about with respect to building RL agents
all right I don't want to go into the
paper too much it's a very cool paper
but we're here to play games and I
invite you to read the paper
check out the website try these games
for yourself they're a lot of fun
especially if you travel first time and